we need to look at something astounding
that happened over the course of like a
hundred years
this is the final chapter and what I
think is the most mind-boggling chapter
in the story of how Europe took over the
world the reason why it's so
mind-boggling is because this is the
part of the story where the map goes
from looking like this in 1800 with
Europe controlling like 35 percent of
the world's land to looking like this by
1914.
with 84 percent of the Earth being
controlled by the people or the
descendants of the people from this once
isolated continent in Europe 84 how on
Earth did this happen
a huge part of this next chapter has to
do with this continent the second
largest continent on Earth and the part
of the world that the Europeans hadn't
really carved up yet
so this is where the whole story comes
together it shows us how technology and
different ways of thinking helped these
people take over the world and in the
process shaped the world we live in
today the way that we trade where we get
our stuff the language I'm using to
speak to right now and most of you
understand it even though you don't live
anywhere near the place where it was
invented I'm telling you this isn't far
away history anymore this is the world
we currently live in so let me show you
the third and final chapter of how
Europe stole the world
foreign
[Music]
maps and I'm telling you this is the
chapter where the maps get really good
cartography really took off okay let's
get up to speed on where we're at
remember it all started with Spain and
Portugal they ramped up this colonialism
thing back around 1500 and this led them
to divide the world between them until
other European countries got in on it
too then the real competition started
the Dutch created the modern corporation
which allowed them to speed all of this
up the world quickly turned into a giant
Marketplace run by Europeans with boats
and guns and incentives to bring profits
to the shareholders back home
foreign
this is all a huge part of the story but
I'm telling you when it comes to scale
imperialism is just getting started and
that's because Europeans are about to
level up we're going to call this
imperialism 2.0 a new way of taking over
the world fueled mostly by technology
and a rare cooperation between all of
these Empires
one British prime minister described
this imperialism 2.0 as quote the vulgar
and bastard imperialism of irritation
and aggression of grabbing everything
even if we had no use for it
but let me tell you if you're like me
and you kind of have a low-key implicit
belief that European domination was
inevitable and that this was going to
happen no matter what I'm here to tell
you that it almost didn't happen that's
because by the end of the 1700s
Revolution was in the air
[Music]
Empires were losing their colonies
starting with a group of Europeans who
were done having a king and declaring
independence for themselves in the late
1700s soon you had a bunch of Spanish
colonies declaring independence and then
over here in Haiti you had enslaved
people who were organizing and rebelling
against their French Masters throwing
them out and starting their own country
these Empires weren't only losing their
colonies back in Europe one ruler even
lost his head in all of this the empires
were losing their grip and soon they
were fighting with one another like
never before it was chaos and it totally
freaked these European rulers out are
they losing their empire are they going
to lose their reins on power is the era
of abundance and domination coming to an
end no we can't let this happen so they
start doing something that was kind of
unheard of instead of fighting and
competing with each other like they've
always done the European powers start
talking to each other their Empires were
in Jeopardy and they needed to
collaborate find ways to share power
both at home in Europe but also on the
world stage soon this new culture of
diplomacy and collaboration would turn
to focus on the one continent that none
of these European powers had carved up
yet the new Imperial Frontier certainly
full of resources but not yet conquered
[Music]
I mean the maps tell the story here the
maps were like a record of what
Europeans knew and didn't know about the
world I mean this one British map from
1800s says it all look at this thing
Europeans were differently familiar with
Africa especially here in the coast
where for hundreds of years they had
trading posts and of course the Atlantic
slave trade but look how they mapped the
interior of the continent it literally
just gives up and it's like Inland Parts
almost entirely unknown which is pretty
rare for this time period at this point
the Europeans have really mapped a lot
of the world but this place was off
limits it was the stuff of Legend of
myths the caption here on the map says
that this interior part of Africa may be
considered as absolutely unknown or
completely unexplored all we know says
the map is that its immense and arid
Sands are intersected with complete
collections of the most ferocious beasts
and most uncivilized men
that's all they know
[Music]
there was a very good reason for this
the fact is that soldiers and explorers
from Europe who went into this area a
lot of them didn't come home up to 40
percent died from diseases like the
mosquito-borne illness malaria so much
so that this part of the map became
known as the white man's grave totally
off limits but that soon changed
oh
[Music]
two giant things happen that change
everything completely redirect what
Europeans can do with their mounting
power first these two French guys are
able to take the bark of this tree which
had been used for a very long time for
variety of purposes and isolate a vital
chemical called quinine it combats
malaria the major killer of Europeans
Africa they now have a white man's
shield to protect them from the white
man's grave the door is slowly creaking
open second this guy happens King
Leopold II he's the king of this new
country called Belgium and it existed
for like 40 years it's kind of a minor
place in Europe nothing like these OG
colonizers so it's like 1875 and King
Leopold wants to play with the big boys
he wants a colony so he literally goes
around and starts asking these major
Colonial powers for like some of their
land like he goes to the ogs Spain and
Portugal he's like hey guys I know
you're in Decline can I have one of your
colonies and they're like no so then he
goes to the British and he's like hey
guys I know you have new any maybe you
don't have any plans for it you could
give it to me and they're like no Leo
don't you realize how hard we worked to
steal this land we're not going to give
it to you as a handout so King Leopold
decides to take matters into his own
hands he turns to the map and decides
this part of the map the parts Unknown
where none of the colonizers have
arrived to yet it's a prime place for
his Colony King Leopold sets his sight
on the white man's grave a quick
reminder that this is kind of the
fantasy of the Europeans who haven't
explored this in reality at this point
Africa looks a lot more like this but in
the mind of King Leopold and other
Europeans it's a big blank canvas with
unlimited possibilities
foreign
sends explorers to like the dead center
of this blank canvas and they're armed
not only with some of the latest and
greatest weapons but also with medicine
that Shields them from these killer
tropical diseases these Belgian
explorers arrive and are able to make
agreements with the locals Lane claimed
to this land King Leopold now has his
own little colony in the center of the
white man's grave
and of course they start mapping it
this is a map from a bunch of Belgian
cartographers and explorers when they
first arrive to this center part of
Africa very little detail here at the
beginning this is 1880. they basically
got this River some of the offshoots but
they don't really know what's going on
in here yet this becomes the frame that
Leopold uses to build his colony
foreign of course this freaks the French
out because they're like hey what's
Belgium doing in Africa why are they
exploring all this land so they decide
to send their own explorers to claim
their own bit of land after all they've
got the medicine it's not nearly as
dangerous and the belgians are doing it
well of course now the British are
waking up they're sending people too and
even the new kid on the Imperial block
Germany is chipping in and now suddenly
we've got to scramble on our hands
[Music]
see the European powers let's learn from
our mistakes instead of the old days
where we always had to fight over things
in this era of Revolution and warfare
remember that we're trying to be better
about talking to one another
coordinating remember until it's 1884
and all these big Africa hungry European
Empires get together in Berlin I mean
this is amazing painting of just them
all sitting here looking at this big
beautiful map which would be like an
amazing activity to do until you realize
what's actually happening here you've
got the chancellor of Germany you've got
the OG colonizers Portugal explaining
this place to Belgium and France and
Italy and you've even got the new
country the United States who showed up
kind of new to all this Imperial stuff
but quickly learning how power really
works on the international stage
basically anyone in Europe who didn't
have an Empire yet got in now oh and
crucially they didn't invite any African
leaders and to be clear this painting
isn't like exaggerated like it's not a
political cartoon this is literally a
bunch of European dudes in a room in
Berlin in 1884 discussing and
coordinating how they're going to carve
up and take this continent and they
decided that there was going to be one
big rule for this new Scramble for
Africa no pretending none of this only
on the map fake imperialism thing that
the pope arranged for Spain and Portugal
a few hundred years previous you
actually have to control the land if
you're going to claim it so they divide
up the map on who gets what they leave
the conference and they get to work
the French start moving in quickly from
West Africa the British begin taking
over Sudan and expanding North from down
here in South Africa to take over all of
this land the Germans really start
establishing themselves here and over
here Italy starts occupying all this
land up here in the north and east and
Leopold well he got his Colony 77 times
the size of Belgium here it was as a
blank canvas when they first started
exploring in 1880
here it is 14 years later little Belgium
down here giant Congo up here the
blueprint has filled out the conquest is
complete with his new Colony King
Leopold of course went on to do horrible
things exploiting pillaging the
resources from this place and wreaking
horrible havoc on the people and it is
horrific and it is horrendous and I made
a whole other video that kind of goes
into it more I'll link to it and go to
the sources in the description please
okay
all of these Empires were carving up
this map coming in mapping it very
beautifully it's like literally the
opposite of what it was it was unknown
and now it's totally known pillaging the
resources bringing it back home making
record profits etc etc and all of this
this carving it happened really fast
foreign
but wait a minute hold on pause how does
this make any sense like it made sense
when it was all like on water and there
were ships and there was domination and
trading ports and all of that but this
this is an incredibly logistically
ambitious thing to do like this was
actually a central question for me that
led me to make this series because I
just didn't understand how these
countries in a matter of a few years
could completely carve up the second
largest continent well the answer to
that question isn't that surprising
these Europeans now had a leg up they
had new tools
remember they had invented capitalism to
make them Rich that gave them time to do
science which gave them technology that
they used to make their capitalism
better and more effective more
productive this cycle repeated itself
over and over and over giving Europeans
a further and further leg up
technologically until soon they had
stuff like this a steamboat you didn't
have to worry about the wind anymore to
keep going you could just steam your way
all the way up African rivers and the
old African queen or the railroad quick
way to transport food and troops like
you can see this map all of this red is
either railroads that they put in or
railroads that they were constructing at
this time this allowed Europeans to
level up not just in Africa but
everywhere I mean here they are in India
the British quickly taking over this
entire subcontinent of what today's
India and Pakistan and Bangladesh with
this massive complex rail system that
they built basically in no time they
also invented the telegraph which could
now relay messages in a matter of
minutes instead of weeks I mean this
political cartoon really personifies how
powerful this was and of course what
we've been looking at this whole time
they made Maps
big beautiful juicy maps showing the
geography and the people and all of the
land that they had conquered in addition
to technology these Empires had also
perfected the art of allying with local
power holders and turning the people
against each other divide and conquer
which allowed a small group of Europeans
to control millions of locals and of
course
they had these
[Music]
these refined killing machines that
allowed small groups of European
soldiers to rip through truly formidable
African armies like look at this
painting from Sudan where the British
used their guns to slaughter 10 000
enemies with just a few hundred losses
and hear this casual caption showing
that these Savages were now mowed down
by these modern weapons of war clearing
way for civilization
now it wasn't this easy everywhere
descendants of white Dutch settlers held
off the British for a long time down
here in South Africa and the Ethiopians
were able to hold off the Italians from
conquering their land making it the only
place in Africa to never be colonized
but listen in the midst of all this
Bloodshed we have to talk about
something that doesn't fit cleanly into
our Narrative of good versus evil
because the presence of these Europeans
in this continent also brought really
positive things remember those French
Dudes that discovered the treatment for
malaria well that was tested in the
field in French Algeria a colony it
changed medicine forever giving us our
modern understanding of mosquitoes and
the diseases they spread the scramble
into Africa helped push forward our
understanding of health and disease and
medicine these and tons of other medical
developments and help these Europeans
conquer land but it also brought
Innovation that we still use today that
has saved countless lives
okay so technology was a major defining
Factor but it wasn't just technology
once again we see in this chapter what
we saw in other chapters that Europeans
had to develop new sophisticated mental
inventions that allowed this all to go
down the popular story that they were
telling themselves at this time was that
all civilization could be ranked
according to the level of development
and look according to this analysis they
placed themselves at the top and they
could tell themselves very easily that
they were the enlightened people of the
world this new colonizing story was the
most sophisticated and tantalizing yet
and it's one that's still kind of
embedded in a lot of our brains still
that the enlightened civilization had a
burden to bring civilization to the rest
of the world and for that they kind of
needed to stay on top and control and
the reason why this story was so
believable and tantalizing is because at
this time it was being blended with
actual real objective science that was
being done by Europeans like this guy
Charles Darwin someone who changed the
way that we think about the natural
world he just put out a book about how
animals evolve into hierarchies with
different capabilities and traits well
if that applies to all animals then it
must apply to humans themselves and
their societies and their civilizations
so then they got into the field with
their maps and they start Gathering
observations that confirm this story and
soon they're measuring people's skulls
all around the world they're keeping
notes they're developing theories and
terms they're writing academic papers
all of this to define a pretend set of
pseudo-scientific ideas the idea that
we're all part of a different race all
with different natural capabilities and
that is what must explain why some
people have the resources in the
technology and others do not like the
previous stories that Europeans told
themselves this one was intoxicating
think of all the generations that passed
where this story could be ingrained into
the minds of the people
but again remember that like I'm not
saying that these Europeans are telling
themselves this story every day we're
now talking about the great great great
grandchildren of like the original
colonizers the individual people didn't
have the grand plan in mind to go carve
up Africa they were just responding to
what they knew what they'd been told was
real what they wanted to believe it was
a way of life it was a way of thinking
and if we think that we're somehow
exempt from a similar type of mental
model that we don't see but that
dictates our Behavior we're tricking
ourselves I mean listen to one of these
British imperialists Cecil Rhodes he
says we happen to be the best people in
the world with the highest ideals of
decency and Justice Liberty and peace
and the more of the world we inhabit the
better it is for Humanity
okay Cecil has made up his mind
okay so let's look at the map in like
the early 1900s Africa looks like this
completely carved up by European powers
over here the Dutch had conquered the
entire Indonesian archipelago the French
completely taking over this part of
Southeast Asia but the real Kingpin in
all of this taking over land stuff was
the British Empire in addition to all
this stuff they had in Africa they
occupied the huge Indian subcontinent
they also had a few of these important
ports like Hong Kong and Singapore I
mean I can't go over all of the stuff
they took over because it's just too
much at the peak of their empire they
ruled over 412 million people which was
a ton for that time their domination had
spread to almost 25 percent of the globe
making Britain this rainy set of islands
in Europe the biggest empire that ever
existed in doing so they spread their
people their ideas their economic system
their Fringe language to every corner of
the world including where I'm sitting
right now because remember the U.S is
just one expression of the British
Empire the branch of the Empire that
went on to become the most powerful
country in the world to influence how
the World Order would look by 1914
Europe had successfully taken over the
world
there were deathly Rich compared to the
rest of the globe and their ideas both
good and bad were deeply embedded in the
International System but suddenly all of
this technology all this
industrialization that made them so
effective turned away from conquering
Faraway lands and was turned on each
other
over the next 30 Years hundreds of
millions of people are killed in the two
most destructive Wars ever made possible
by all the same things that allowed
Europeans to take over the world
sophisticated weapons and technology
that Europeans are now turning on each
other the so-called sophisticated race
is now slaughtering one another on an
unprecedented scale these wars didn't do
the image of the Civilized Europeans any
good and Western schooled local Elites
decided that they didn't want to be
ruled by Foreign forces anymore they
were able to Rally their people around a
Common Language and birthed national
identity that didn't include being ruled
by white people from some Far Away
continent and they pushed the colonists
out sometimes peacefully but most often
with Force the Europeans had built this
insane Global project for more than 400
years and yet they saw it crumble in a
matter of decades
so today the map has been severely
redrawn former colonies are now mostly
independent countries there are still a
ton of weird idiosyncratic holdovers
from the colonial period I've talked
about those many times and I will
continue to talk about them
I want to finish this up finish this
video and finish this series up with my
last thought here which is something
that the map doesn't tell us much about
thank you
even though all these countries became
independent and they can claim their own
sovereignty their own borders their
colonizers are gone they didn't actually
not only were there loads of borders
that were literally drawn by colonizers
I mean see basically all of my previous
work but by the end of this it was the
Europeans that had tied the whole world
up into an interconnected system that
still kind of echoed the old one the
Dutch invention of the shareholder
Corporation didn't go away private
companies didn't suddenly stop looking
to the same far-off places to find
resources to find labor to feed
increasing demand among their people
back home and European rulers and their
offspring didn't stop using their big
metal guns and their technology to get
what they wanted in Faraway lands
occasionally talking to each other and
occasionally fighting with each other
fighting to control land to control
people to control ideas and perhaps most
powerfully the idea that our enlightened
way was indeed the best way we will
stand with the new leaders of Iraq as
they establish a government of by and
for the Iraqi people certainly has not
gone away
[Music]
and yet if it were only that simple a
simple Narrative of good and bad greedy
Europeans take over the world and do
anything to stay ahead that would be a
lot easier in some ways but it's not
Europe taking over the world has also
thrust Humanity into an age of peace and
prosperity where people live longer
suffer Less in a lot of ways have more
food to eat I mean the very moral lens
that you and I are using right now to
evaluate the good and bad of this
history that was a lens that was
cultivated and developed by the same
cultures that pillaged and subjugated
their way around the planet these ideals
of justice and equality and human rights
and representation social equality and
self-determination those ideas permeated
the globe alongside the colonizers who
carved it up and yet it was this
Conquest that put these people on top of
the whole system giving us the power and
the advantage
the default power holders in our world
[Music]
three parts have been a story of how an
isolated group of farming people some of
them my ancestors left their Shores to
explore discovering a vast world that
eventually they would find a way to
control and in the process setting the
rules for how things work today
what's slightly scary to me about this
is how easy it is to look back on this
whole history and feel like it was going
to happen this way no matter what that
it was inevitable that of course
Europeans took over the world they were
always more Adept they were bound to
control the planet but if there's
anything I've learned diving into this
broad tour through European imperialism
is that this idea is just hindsight bias
this didn't happen because of some
Superior DNA or because God wanted these
people to take over the world but rather
it happened because a bunch of people
happened to be at the right place that
allowed them to start a chain of
millions of little decisions that pushed
them to do whatever they could to
procure more and more resources they got
ahead because of Lucky circumstances and
yet today in our model world we continue
to do whatever we need to to stay ahead
while simultaneously believing that it
was always going to happen this way
[Music]
it's over
it's it's over I mean the series is over
but the year is over I deserve this not
only is it the end of the Europe series
it's the end of the year and what a year
it has been by the way this video is not
sponsored by anyone probably because
we're in a recession and so I'm going to
take this time to just reflect a little
bit on what this year has meant for me
as a Storyteller and a journalist and
for our team and what we are gonna do
next I think for me the big thing I
learned this year was that we can build
a big operation like for a long time it
was just me kind of pushing buttons on a
laptop and like making stories and this
year it actually became a team we now
have lots and lots of people making
really really cool stuff a very talented
team and we're doing journalism on a
level that we've never done we go really
deep on every fact that we say on this
channel and that requires a lot of work
sometimes that feels really tiresome but
a lot of the time that feels exciting
that we on YouTube can be doing like
hardcore journalism and fun stuff too
obviously we got to do a few in the
field documentaries this year which was
really amazing I went to Paris and Korea
and Switzerland we printed a lot of
amazing maps and showed you what Maps
were like over the years and what they
were used for oh and my hair got really
long because I decided for the first
time in my life not to cut it and that's
making my whole no shampoo thing a
little more complicated maybe I'll make
a video about that anyway
all right
I ate a lot of Doritos like a lot of
Doritos like I really like Doritos even
after I know how they're made but in my
mind this is kind of just the beginning
like I want this to be the beginning I
want like four years from now to look
back and be like oh yeah 2022 that was
the year that we really started to ramp
up and that gets me to the thing that
I'm really excited about that we
launched this year which is a community
on patreon called The Newsroom a place
where people like you support us and
what we're trying to do here and allow
us to grow more and more and especially
during economic downturn and
unpredictability this work that we do
relies on community support on people
like you showing up and supporting us
and it's our Newsroom supporters that
are allowing us to do better work to do
more of it and I'm very grateful for
that in addition to supporting
independent journalism Newsroom members
also get access to a bunch of cool stuff
like a behind the scenes Vlog and extra
video every month there's a lot of
really talented interesting people
behind the scenes and every month you
get a vlog where you see how it's all
done you get access to music from our
composer Tom Fox you get access to my
scripts occasionally we do q and A's
where we get to chat I do polls where I
get story ideas it's become a really
cool community of supporters and just a
kind of a sounding board for cool ideas
oh and here's a big one we've started
publishing our videos over on nebula
which is a Creator owned platform where
you can get our videos a week early
there's a link in my description that
explains all that if you want to support
the channel and you're like a production
person then we have Luts and presets
which help us color our videos and
photos and if you don't want to support
the channel and you just want to keep
watching
um that's fine too I'm not here to tell
you to give me money I'm here to make
cool stories and I hope that you're
learning from these videos and I
appreciate you being here in the first
place so let's raise a glass to a
wonderful year of learning and growth
and amazing Stories and look forward to
a 2023 that I hope is going to be full
of even more growth not only growth in
the number of people that are here but
also a growth in our or desire to like
understand this world to understand the
story of how we all got here and how it
works today I will continue to be the
Curious Storyteller who tries to bring
those stories to you in the best way
possible I appreciate all those who are
here supporting and cheers to a great
2023 of curiosity and a lot of maps bye
everyone
foreign
[Music]